Okay, let's take a step back for a second and talk about the major pieces of
the Web, or, or, or the major concepts
we're going to be discussing in this lesson. The major
pieces are you, your computer running a Web
browser, the Internet, and servers. Your browser makes requests
via the Internet to servers. These requests are
using a protocol called http and the servers respond
with files that your browser displays. Some examples of browsers are
Internet Explorer, Chrome, Firefox. You're probably running one of
those right now. These servers are computers just like yours
except they are optimized for sitting in
a closet and hosting files rather than sitting
on your desk, you know, browsing these files. And the protocol http that we are
speaking is, is just a very simple protocol that your
browser uses to communicate with these servers. We'll discuss each of
these pieces. Well, we won't spend a whole lot of
time on the Internet, but we'll discuss each of these pieces
in turn throughout this lesson. Okay. Time for another quiz.
What I'd like you to do is, take the letters that
are near each piece of technology we just discussed and match
them up with their name and definition. Your options are HTTP,
the main protocol of the Web. Servers, computers that host the files that make
up the Web. The Internet, the worlds
largest computer network. And your browser, a
program that runs on your computer to display files found on the Web. Take
the letters next to each piece of technology and put them in the correct box.